it is one thing to study war and another
to live the Warriors life Telemann of
Arcadia mercenary of the fifth century
BC professionals and amateurs aspiring
artists defeated by resistance share one
trait they all think like amateurs they
have not yet turned pro the moment an
artist turns pro is as epical as the
birth of his first child with one stroke
everything changes I can say Tab
solutely that the term of my life can be
divided into two parts before turning
pro and after to be clear when I say
professional I don't mean doctors and
lawyers those of the professions I mean
the professional as an ideal the
professional in contrast to the amateur
consider the differences the amateur
plays for fun the professional place for
keeps to the amateur the game is his
avocation to the pro it's his vocation
the amateur plays part-time the
professional full-time the amateur is a
weekend warrior the professional is
there seven days a week the word amateur
comes from the latin root meaning to
love the conventional interpretation is
that the amateur pursues his calling out
of love while the pro does it for money
not the way i see it in my view the
amateur does not love the game enough if
he did he would not pursue it as a
sideline distinct from his real vocation
the professional loves it so much he
dedicates his life to it he commits
full-time that's what I mean when I say
turning pro resistance hates it when we
turn pro
a professional someone once asked
Somerset mom if he wrote on a schedule
or only when struck by inspiration I
write only when inspiration strikes he
replied fortunately it strikes every
morning at nine o clock sharp that's a
pro in terms of resistance mom was
saying I despise resistance I will not
let it faze me I will sit down and do my
work mom reckoned another deeper truth
that by performing the mundane physical
act of sitting down and starting to work
he set in motion a mysterious but
infallible sequence of events that would
produce inspiration as surely as if the
goddess had synchronized her watch with
his he knew if he built it she would
come what a writer's day feels like I
wake up with a knowing sensation of
dissatisfaction already I feel fear
already the loved ones around me are
starting to fade I interact I'm present
but I'm not I'm not thinking about the
work I've already consigned that to the
muse
what I am aware of is resistance I feel
it in my guts I afforded the utmost
respect because I know it can defeat me
on any given day as easily as the need
for a drink can overcome an alcoholic I
go through the chores the correspondence
the obligations of daily life again I'm
there but not really the clock is
running in my head I know I can indulge
in daily crap for a little while but I
must cut it off when the bell rings I'm
keenly aware of the principle of
priority which states a you must know
the difference between what is urgent
and what is important and B you must do
what's important first what's important
is the work that's the game I have to
suit up for that's the field on which I
have to leave everything I've got do I
really believe that my work is crucial
to the planets survival
course not but it's as important to me
as catching that Mouse is to the hawk
circling outside my window he's hungry
he needs a kill
so do I I'm done with my chores now it's
time I say my prayer and head out on a
hunt the Sun isn't up yet it's cold the
fields are sopping brambles scratched my
ankles branches snap back in my face the
hill is a son of a [ __ ] for what can
you do set one foot in front of another
and keep climbing an hour of passes I'm
warmer now the pace has got my blood
going the years have taught me one skill
how to be miserable I know how to shut
up and keep humping this is a great
asset because it's human the proper role
for a mortal it does not offend the gods
but elicits their intercession my
bitching self is receding now the
instincts are taking over another hour
passes I turn the corner of a thicket
and there he is the nice fat hair I knew
would show up if I just kept [ __ ]
home from the hill I thank the Immortals
and offer up their portion of the kill
they brought it to me they deserve their
share I am grateful I joke with my kids
beside the fire they're happy the old
man has brought home the bacon the old
lady's happy she's cooking it up I'm
happy I've earned my keep on the planet
at least for this day resistance is not
a factor now I don't think of the hunt
and I don't think of the office the
tension drains from my neck and back
what I feel and say and do this night
will not be coming from any disowned or
unresolved part of me any part corrupted
by resistance I go to sleep content but
my final thought is of resistance I will
wake up with it tomorrow already
I'm stealing myself
how to be miserable in my younger days
dodging the draft I somehow wound up in
the Marine Corps there's a myth that
Marine training turns baby-faced
recruits into bloodthirsty killers trust
me the Marine Corps is not that
efficient what it does teach however is
a lot more useful the Marine Corps
teaches you how to be miserable this is
invaluable for an artist Marines love to
be miserable
Marines derive a perverse satisfaction
in having colder Chow crappier equipment
and higher casualty rates than any
outfit of dogfaces
swab jockeys or fly boys all of whom
they despise why because these candy
asses don't know how to be miserable the
artists committing himself to his
calling has volunteered for hell whether
he knows it or not he will be dining for
the duration on a diet of isolation
rejection self-doubt despair ridicule
contempt and humiliation the artist must
be like that Marine he has to know how
to be miserable he has to love being
miserable he has to take pride in being
more miserable than any soldier or
swabby or jet jockey because this is a
war baby and war is hell we're all pros
already all of us are pros in one area
our jobs we get a paycheck we work for
money we are professionals
now are there principles we can take
from what we're already successfully
doing in our workday life and apply to
our artistic aspirations what exactly
are the qualities that define us as
professionals 1 we show up every day we
might do it only because we have to to
keep from getting fired but we do it we
show up every day 2 we show up no matter
what in sickness and in health come hell
or high water we stagger into the
factory we might do it only so as not to
let down our co-workers or for other
less noble reasons but we do it
we show up no matter what we stay on the
job all day our minds may wander but our
bodies remain at the wheel we pick up
the phone when it rings we assist the
customer when he seeks our help
we don't go home till the whistle blows
for we are committed over the long haul
next year we may go to another job
another company another country but
we'll still be working until we hit the
lottery we are part of the labor force
five the stakes for us are high and real
this is about survival feeding our
families educating our children it's
about eating six we accept remuneration
for our labor we're not here for fun we
work for money 7 we do not over identify
with our jobs we may take pride in our
work we may stay late and come in on
weekends but we recognize that we are
not our job descriptions the amateur on
the other hand over identifies with his
avocation his artistic aspiration he
defines himself by it he is a musician a
painter a playwright resistance loves
this resistance knows that the amateur
composer will never write his symphony
because he is overly invested in its
success and over terrified of its
failure the amateur takes it so
seriously it paralyzes him 8 we mastered
the technique of our jobs 9 with a sense
of humor about our jobs 10 we receive
praise or blame in the real world now
consider the amateur the aspiring
painter the wannabe playwright
how does he pursue his calling 1 he
doesn't show up every day 2 he doesn't
show up no matter what 3 he doesn't stay
on the job all day he is not committed
over the long haul the stakes for him
are illusory and fake he does not get
money and he over identifies with his
art he does not have a sense of humor
about fair
you don't hear him bitching this [ __ ]
trilogy is killing me and said he
doesn't write his trilogy at all the
amateur has not mastered the technique
of his art nor does he exposed himself
to judgment in the real world if we show
our poem to our friend and our friend
says it's wonderful I love it
that's not real-world feedback that's
our friend being nice to us nothing is
as empowering as real-world validation
even if it's for failure the first
professional writing job I ever had
after 17 years of trying was on a movie
called King Kong lives I and my partner
at the time Ron Xiu set a brilliant
writer and producer who also did alien
and Total Recall hammered out the
screenplay for Dino De Laurentiis we
loved it we were sure we had a hit even
after we'd seen the finished film we
were certain it was a blockbuster we
invited everyone we knew to the premiere
even rented out the joint next door for
a post Triumph blowout get there early
we warned our friends the place will be
mobbed nobody showed there was only one
guy in line beside our guests and he was
muttering something about spare change
in the theater our friends endured the
movie in mute stupefaction when the
lights came up they fled like
cockroaches into the night next day came
the review and Variety Ronald said and
Stephen Pressfield we hope these are not
their real names for their parents sake
when the first week's grosses came in
the flick barely registered still I
clung to hope maybe it's only tanking in
urban areas maybe it's playing better in
the burbs I motored to an edge city
multiplex a youth man the popcorn booth
house King Kong lives I asked he flashed
thumbs down misuk man it sucks I was
crushed here I was 42 years old divorced
childless having given up all normal
human pursuits to chase the dream of
being a writer now I finally got my name
on a big
time Hollywood production starring Linda
Hamilton and what happens I'm a loser a
phony
my life is worthless and so am I my
friend Tony couple men snapped me out of
it by asking if I was going to quit
hell no then be happy you're where you
wanted to be aren't you so you're taking
a few blows that's the price for being
in the arena and not on the sidelines
stop complaining and be grateful that
was when I realized I had become a pro I
had not yet had a success but I had had
a real failure
for